four years 160 million dollars that's 40
million a year and there's different
ways that you can slice and dice a
contract and evaluate it but
i've looked at this thing every possible
way this is even though it's only four
years but the fact that it's only four
years is one of the reasons why it's so
good to pay out this kind of money
with only four years and to eliminate or
at least minimize the dummy years on the
back end that allow the team to control
the guy and have a year-to-year option
there's one year for the cowboys where
they have a team held option it's the
last year of the deal if it's just not
working out it's three years 126 million
42 million a year and the cowboys could
rip it up after three years with minimal
consequence there's no guaranteed money
that goes into that fourth year so
this is a very real contract for dak
prescott 40 million dollars average it's
signing 40 million in new money we'll
talk about that distinction coming up 66
million signing bonus chris that's a
record 75 million paid out completely
with no deferral this year wow that's a
record and 95 million fully guaranteed
at signing fully guaranteed one of the
key factors how much fully guaranteed
when you put your name on paper 95
million on a four-year deal that is
amazing and also a record and only on a
four-year deal yeah it is i mean it's
it's mind-blowing it's one of those
things when you see it you just go whoa
like those are big numbers that's big
money you know good for him first thing
i want to ask you right all right like
because of course this is a great deal
for doc prescott we know that i give
jerry jones and everybody a lot of
credit uh certainly for getting this
done when you you know you got your guy
but do you think i just this just comes
into my mind does does jerry look at
this and go well i got my five-year deal
because i franchised him last year you
know that's just the first thing that
came to my head is that where he goes
okay fine i'll give you your four
because i kind of cheated you with five
and you know you add the
31.9 million or whatever he made last
year and now it becomes an average of
what 39 or something like that right in
that that ballpark do you think jerry
looks at it like that or do they just
wipe the slate clean and just go here's
a new four-year deal
i doubt that last year yeah it came out
191.4
million over
over five years
with the 31.4 guaranteed and then after
one season the season in which you
suffer a badly broken ankle you still
have 126 million guaranteed total 31
million of it is guaranteed for injury
95 million fully guaranteed at signing i
think jerry will tell himself yeah right
right to feel better about this but they
blew it by waiting yes that's the bottom
line yes they blew it by waiting and now
they're gonna be right back in the same
spot
in three years after three years and 126
million they're going to be embarking on
the final year of a contract for dak
prescott
with no ability whatsoever as a
practical matter or otherwise to ever
apply the franchise tag to him again
this is part of what you get yeah when
you have the leverage chris to get it
all sure now there was a report
yesterday that the deal will have a no
tag clause and a no trade clause no
trade let's talk about the no trade
clause for a second this is becoming
more and more common in these franchise
quarterback contracts
and for a true franchise quarterback i
think it's meaningless look at carson
wentz and the bears carson wentz didn't
want anything to do with the bears so
the bears aren't going to try to bring
carson wentz to town exactly if you have
a franchise quarterback who doesn't want
to play for you you're not going to
trade for him right regardless of what
his contract says about a no trade
clause no agree the the no trade clause
is not really necessary for like the top
quarterbacks in football you're right
there's
the there that's the old you know thing
we've talked about yeah okay we're gonna
bring a quarterback in here that doesn't
really want to be here and he's gonna
you know say all these negative things
in the locker room and be grumpy and
unhappy and all those type of things
nobody wants that so that that makes no
sense and then you know you get back to
the the four-year contract of what dak
press got made and all that hey you know
i'm sure yeah he's gonna get back to the
market but it's rare that we see like
you know i they i think they look at it
and go well we think he's going to be
here for a long time at some point we're
going to renegotiate before that fourth
year is over and we'll figure it out
then because you don't usually see
better yeah i know better you usually
don't see talents like deck prescott
leave town and i understand people are
going to go oh carson wentz or jared
goff listen he's not carson wentz or
jared goff there's he's better there's
just no other way to say it and you know
hey carson wentz said his best at his
play there okay maybe it's close but he
doesn't have all the other issues carson
wentz has that's what i was you know
saying a little bit earlier on i mean
when you got your guy you got to make a
move and and make sure you secure them
and they got a guy that is a top 10
quarterback in the nfl he's a top 10
quarterback he's a top 10 leader and he
does all the things as far as top 10
face of the franchise type of guys too
that you want your star and your name
and everything to be associated with a
guy like that so from that standpoint i
understand them giving up this type of
money listen you know me i'm always like
well
you know i does it always have to be the
next guy up gets more money well i know
you know
mahomes is still the leader in the
leader house there with 45 million per
year but it's not really that as we've
talked about god's contract way better
immensely better i got it
because when this contract ends patrick
mahomes is still going to be committed
for seven more years to the chiefs and
who knows how different the world is
going to be then from a cap standpoint
from a revenue standpoint no i know that
too and then you know that still goes
back into the conversation the moment
four years from now when patrick mahomes
says he wants a new contract he'll get
one so that's not going to be an issue
either but either way this is hey that's
a good point great point great point
here's the thing yeah the chiefs can be
trusted by patrick mahomes
when things get off definitely when he
gets surpassed by others they'll tear up
the contract and give him another one i
think part of the problem here and this
gets back to what we were talking about
yesterday with the american oligarchy
jerry jones was never going to tear up
and you think he's going to tear a bad
deal you think if jerry jones had the
patrick mahomes contract do you think if
dak prescott had just taken the patrick
home's contract remember i said last
year if you if and people lost their
minds if you put the contract in front
of dak prescott removed patrick mahomes
name and put in back prescott's name he
would tell you to shove it he's not
signing that contract people like who
does he think he is well he's not
signing that contract and one of the
reasons why the cowboys would not cut
you any breaks down the road they're not
going to say well you know the market
really has outperformed what we thought
it would and and and the the salary caps
gone up and you really have a bad deal
here well sucks for you good for us bad
for you that's america that's capitalism
that's how they've made all their money
is doing good deals the cowboys aren't
ripping that thing up the chiefs who
once upon a time were the crosstown
rivals of the cowboys when they were the
dallas texans they're going to rip that
up at the appropriate time because they
want to keep their guy happy no doubt i
would think so and the fact that they're
gonna be able to look at it and go man
we were kind of in a tight spot when we
wanted to give you you know your last
contract with tyree kill and chris jones
and all those things and i think they'll
do them a solid and you know try to do
their best there but obviously patrick
mahomes didn't care i mean that's that's
another thing that just jumps out to you
about this contract when you compare it
just apples to apples he was willing to
sacrifice a lot of money and things to
make sure the team is really good around
him we'll and we'll see and like you've
always said i'm not trying to argue
there's anything wrong it's not your job
to worry about the team it's the owners
and the and the gm and everything like
that i get it uh but still like kristin
throw that last graphic up there
i mean this blows out over the first
four years yeah it just blows it blows
everybody out of the water i mean it
this is a total game changer to where i
mean every top quarterback in football
is looking at this right now going damn
i got ripped off or damn jerry's got a
lot of cash either way that's the other
thing that popped into my mind like just
just off topic a little here
i i mean did jerry supposedly you know
hit it rich right two weeks ago with the
power outage he'd still have he'd still
have the money i know i just didn't know
maybe it was a little extra cash that
came in to where he goes okay okay it
didn't matter all right fine whatever
whatever extra money he made or didn't
make this is a deal they had to do
because otherwise as we discussed
yesterday and previous times before that
dak prescott could have just said i'm
going forward under this franchise tag
3768 and i'll become a free agent next
year so that put that graphic back up
let's make sure people understand what
this is this is the payout under the
first four years of the current
contracts these quarterbacks have so
when russell wilson signed his latest
deal he had a year left on it the first
four years under that new deal when you
rip up the existing deal and put a new
one in place pays out 131 dak prescott
29 million north of that aaron rodgers
his most recent deal four years under
his most recent deal 124.5
blown out of the water by dak prescott
and you know aaron rodgers may look at
this and say oh hey
oh wait a minute here something's wrong
with this picture but you know what
roger's never played out his leverage to
the hilt right he would always take that
that six-year contract six-year
extension remember when he signed his
his second big deal with the packers in
2013 i think it was he committed all the
way through 2019
so
that's what prescott avoided having the
team control the back end of the deal
when it becomes a year-to-year
proposition and there's nothing binding
player to team
the cowboys are bound to prescott for
the next three years that fourth year is
where the action is going to be
that's where the the cowboys and
prescott need to work out something new
or he is walking away or at least
walking to the open market and we'll let
the market determine his value right
after four seasons chris because of
threat and this shows you the lack of
trust the lack of and and it's not a bad
way it's it's what trust but verify or
whatever the term is but the the
prescott and his agents weren't willing
to just blindly assume that the cowboys
are going to play ball here so they got
protection three different ways
to avoid a franchise tag in
2025 march of 2025 the first there will
be a no tag clause it wasn't in the
contract as of last night there will be
one
secondly
there's two avoidable years on the back
end of this deal and i don't want to get
into the weeds on this this is about cap
management and the cowboys being able to
shove cap dollars into future years
down the line and right now spreading it
out over more years those two years go
away after the 2024 season they go away
the way it's written they go away those
years are never going to happen
but here's the beauty of it the demarcus
lawrence deal
it has voidable years that go away in
advance of the deadline for applying the
franchise tag so the contract goes away
in theory the cowboys that have the
ability to tag him after the years go
away dak prescott's avoidable years go
away after the deadline for applying the
franchise tag so he's not even eligible
to be tagged when his years go away so
he can't be tagged that way and then the
third thing is
they required
the cowboys to apply the second tag they
required it it's been called a
procedural move baloney dak prescott his
agent said you're applying this tag
because the next tag
is a 44 raise over whatever my cap
number was he's never getting tagged
again for his entire career cowboys or
anyone else i mean he could but it's a
44 percent bump yeah right three
different ways three different ways to
ensure he's getting to the market in
2025 if they don't extend the deal at
some point before the end of the 2024
section well yeah i mean i this is one
of those where and again i'm not i don't
know every detail here but i i know all
the basics here from what we've seen
last night and what you've written in on
pro football talk and everything
i mean yeah i mean the fourth year i
would doubt we even get to the fourth
year i'm expecting to hear renegotiation
right around there like you kind of
earlier said you know it's rarely you
see and they it looks like they believe
totally in dak prescott that they got
their guy it's rarely you see a
franchise guy in his prime walk away
from his team you know and i think
they're also thinking hey we've done a
good job of you know setting up some
talent around you and doing those things
where you know franchise quarterbacks
especially once you get 95 million
dollars in your you know pocket in the
first year
you start to okay i'm good i'm set up
for life 75 i'm 75. i'm sorry 95. over
two what is it when does he get 95 95
over two 95 over two damn it's a lot of
money but yes you know once you get to
that point that's when yo it's year four
hey dak we want to sign this guy on
defense we want to do this
and as a player and as a quarterback
you're so established at one place
and you've got an environment and things
around you that you're used to you like
you don't want to go to a new place and
start a new challenge and have to deal
with all of that to where it's it's very
rare and unlikely that he wouldn't be
there and i would think it's going to be
something redone you know in that fourth
year give them some more money up front
right and then they'll figure out a way
to lessen a number or whatever to play
with that but
uh i don't look at it as a big deal or
as a threat as dak prescott's gonna be
out there in four years or anything
right right but chris yeah maximum
leverage he's gonna hear right next time
around because there's no franchise tag
to be had after these four years that's
his leverage that's his hammer when they
get into 2024 the fourth year of this
deal
he just has to
you know what do you want you want it
all and and and look we're going to have
the pearl clutches out there who
who oh oh you're never going to win a
super bowl well okay
maybe i will maybe i won't but i yeah
you know but my grandkids are set up for
life
well grandkids and their grandkids are
going to be set up for life the way this
thing's going if he gets another deal
like this and think about where the
world's going to be three years from now
where the where the tv money is going to
be three years from now yeah where
gambling will be three years from now
you know this idea of
and again patrick mahomes has a lot of
faith in the kansas city chiefs and
and that faith will be returned and that
faith is worthwhile as long as he plays
like we've seen him play but whether
it's stack whether it's patreon homes
whether it's tom brady whether it's
anyone else the moment you no longer
have value to the team you're gone
you're done right so you know this this
balance this philosophical thing what we
talked about yesterday how much is
enough yeah everything is enough
everything is enough you get everything
you can because none of this other stuff
can be controlled you can't control
whether or not you're gonna win a super
bowl you can go out and play your best
you got 21 of the guys on the field and
hey the cowboys have done a good job
drafting as evidenced by the fact that
they got dak prescott in round four sure
go out and draft some guys you've got
devices that make it easier for you to
go out and get players who are cheap who
you can put around me so you go do your
job i'll do my job and off we go and
that is so contrary to the tom brady
approach and i've seen people
comparing dak prescott to tom brady and
tom brady's only making 25 million this
year and tom brady's working on super
bowl number eight well good for him good
for him he made his choices and we we've
talked about the psychology of life with
belichick and one of the reasons why he
was taken less he was afraid that
belichick was going to say i'm paying
this guy too much money i'm getting rid
of him yeah but as long as you're
earning that money you're gonna stay the
moment they think you're not no matter
who you are the moment they think they
can do better than you you're gone so
get what you can while you can while you
have your skills and while you have a
team that's willing to give it to you
because the moment that window closes
they are they they will have thrown you
out of it right before it closes no
there's no doubt i mean it's it's it's
brutal i've learned it firsthand i saw
my dad go through it i mean it's it's
it's a it's a cutthroat business it's
the most cut throat but you went through
it i knew it through it you did the
buccaneers a favor did they do you a
favor after you lost your spleen no you
know well you know they gave me a they
gave me a two-year contract and gave me
a little money they did i will say that
the glazier family stepped up and gave
me a little something after the fact to
where that year after i couldn't play
now they didn't know i wasn't going to
be able to play at that point i think
they thought oh everything will be hunky
dory and all that but they did try to do
they thought they were buying low they
thought they were buying they thought
they were buying low and they were
giving me you know a little competition
the fact that i almost died i think but
yeah i mean you're right but but either
way no once they realized i wasn't
normal and everything like that gruden
wanted to sell my butt down the river he
didn't give a damn anymore after that
how long how long did it take them to
figure out that you're not normal uh it
took me about three weeks well mentally
normal they were already in on that
physically normal it was not long after
the spleen where it just got worse and
worse really but you're right it's
cutthroat and this is where you know
it is interesting when you sign this
kind of contract this kind of money
hey doc prescott's going to have a lot
of pressure on them there's no doubt
about it like if they don't play well
it's going to be exactly what you said
it's going to be a lot of that well i
mean you're taking all the money how can
we have a defense how can we do that and
all those type of things but
where this one's a little different and
i look at dak and go
yeah he's gonna have the pressure
but man the one thing he's got is
support around them and talent around
him
and
you know i would be shocked again with
this wide receiving core they got the
o-line yeah it's aging but it's still
good that i would be shocked that he's
not one of the statistically one of the
five best quarterbacks in football once
again they're gonna ride him it's about
the passing game and that added to the
leverage too to what you talked about
yesterday you know the days of zeke and
zack martin and and you know uh and and
uh the tyron smith dominating the line
of scrimmage and we're gonna run for
five yards no matter what defense it's
over it's over zeke is not a top five
running back the o line is not a top 50
line anymore so you mentioned all like
the money leverage that dak prescott had
the team right now the only strength of
the team you can look at really is to go
the pass game and it ain't that strong
without number
dak prescott uh number four i haven't
almost like banked out on his damn
number here but it ain't that strong
without him as we saw last year
and you know like we've talked about a
lot jerry's getting up there in years
and he you don't want to start back at
square one trying to find a quarterback
when you got one so i'm really happy for
dak prescott you know i know i've pushed
back a little bit about like what what's
he asking for was it realistic and all
those things listen i'm just talking you
know because i i had a few people
challenge me like that last night no
it's not i'm i'm cool with that prescott
he's he's the man he's the cover of my
twitter page i really like the guy i'm a
big fan so i'm happy to see him get that
money only because you're in it i mean
it's not like it's not okay i took other
pictures with other guys i took i got
other pictures of quarterbacks okay so
the hell with you is it the side eye is
the side eye the cover of your twitter
page it is it's the bed i only i only
messed with dak prescott on the bed and
things like that that's all we did
that's all we did okay 371 passing yards
per game is what he was averaging last
year before his injury now his injury
was in week five but he was on pace for
5936 passing yards if he had continued
that and it helps to have the receivers
and the running back in ezekiel elliott
and you have to look on the surface oh
who else can they afford to pay now well
the one thing to keep in mind because
they did this deal with the 66 million
dollar signing bonus the avoidable years
you can spread that 66 out five years
reduces his signing bonus cap charge
this year to 11 million throw on the
nine million
in salary that's 22 million yeah uh 21
million
21 million
you're right it is 22 too that is that
is uh
15 million less than what his cap number
was going to be yeah that's that's why
and i made the argument a few weeks ago
you got to get this deal done before the
start of the new league year because you
got to reduce that cap number right now
it's easier for you to do business and
actually they they think they're going
to have more cap issues next year that's
the cowboys fear next year maybe in part
because they're pushing all these other
dollars into
future years but they have the ability
next year to take the 20 million he's
going to make reduce it as far as they
can turn it into a signing bonus and
spread it out that's why there's two
avoidable years gotcha on there so they
have more room more years that they can
push money into and that that piper has
to be paid at some point but the
thinking is by the time those dollars
hit the cap the cap is going to be
through the roof because of
not just tv
but all the money that the nfl owners
are going gonna make and the teams are
gonna make and the players are gonna
make via the salary cap from gambling
yeah that's the big bet here right no
pun intended and that's why it's so
important for dak to get back to the
market or at least back in position was
renegotiating chris because the world
would be very different three years
three years ago as of right now
sports wagering was not legal it was
legal only in nevada and i don't know
they do it in atlantic city but it was
primarily in nevada right and then after
may 12 i think it was 2018 that's when
the floodgates opened that was less than
three years ago so three years from now
who knows where we're going to be and
and i i think it's always better to do a
shorter deal
you rarely see a quarterback get a
four-year deal at signing four years
russell wilson does four-year extensions
with one year left five-year deal
four-year deal from signing practical
matter renegotiation after three
another big payday coming for dak yeah
and uh amazing of all the teams out
there to be stared down and backed into
a corner it was the cowboys and i i i
i'm told that there is a certain level
of amazement within the cowboys
organization
that prescott and his representatives
got held firm right the way they did
they've never encountered someone who's
held that firm rolled the dice and had
the dice land
when seven is good seven isn't always
good right sometimes it's bad sometimes
it's good this is a good seven for dak
prescott yeah it is and uh i mean it
just again you can't you can't be
happy enough for the guy and mike like
the the the salary cap hit thing
that was the thing that jumped out to me
maybe more than anything because i
expected you know once i looked at the
details and what was what was gonna be
the cap hit this year i just was going
man wait how are they gonna do this and
pay him all this money
and what's his cap hit gonna be
and now how are they gonna fix their
football team because as we've talked
about i mean there's issues yeah there's
there's still some high-end talent at
certain positions but
you know there's there's a lot of needs
on the football team you know through
and through we talked about it a little
yesterday you know they could use in
another corner you know two safeties
yeah you know difference makers on the d
line you know i don't know if there's
anybody really special on the d line
dexter i mean you know lawrence
lawrence's demarcus lawrence is real
good i'm not gonna sit here and tell you
i think he's special so you know the
fact that they were creative and the
jones family and just finding out a way
like you said just spread out the cap
hit and do those type of things yeah the
pied piper's gonna call a few years from
now but either way this is the year
where they got to really do some work
and kind of rebuild their football team
and you see this notable free agents
here i mean not all these guys are must
haves but i would think there's a few on
here that they'd want to keep some are
homegrown talon and let alone they just
need to get out in free agency and and
and get some improvement players there
too so this is a big offseason for the
dallas cowboy organization
i'm calling it now old takes exposed you
can mark me down amari cooper this is
gonna be his last year with dallas
i wouldn't be shocked contract 20
million a year well last with all these
receivers that's putting into the draft
every year all these great receivers 20
million a year for a receiver when
you're paying that much to deck amari
cooper is going to be one of the
eventual victims of this contract not
this year but i think next year i i
think that makes a lot of sense i mean
that that's the good thing about the cd
lamb draft pick that kind of gives them
the flexibility to move on from that you
know and buy themselves some time there
to before they got to pay any of these
other receivers but they're they're
literally at the point where they have
like too many receivers i you they're so
talented at the position that it it's
it's you put it up there with anybody
when they got the right quarterback i
mean that's how good they are it's
explosive they got it all you know when
you talk about cd lamb you know and and
uh and amari cooper added with you know
gallop right i mean that that's that's a
damn good three i i could sit here and
argue michael gallup's a low end number
one in the nfl so when you look at that
that's i think again part of the
leverage too for dak prescott in this to
go wait we got these receivers we better
get a guy who can capitalize on these
guys running all over the field and
doing that type of stuff and i think
that added to the leverage of you know
all the other things that you threw in
there with it
what's the next move for the cowboys now
that they have their biggest order of
business that they've been trying to
close for a couple of years done what do
they do next this offseason i mean to me
mike it kind of goes back to what we
were just saying a second ago the
defensive side of the ball
you know getting some some different men
on the front line there that's where
it's going do you try to resign your
guys or do you say you know what there's
gonna be a bloodletting out there we're
gonna go bargain shopping we we we we
did anything but bargain shop right with
dak right they went they went to the
most expensive section of the store to
get dac so now with whatever they have
left they've got to go down to the
bargain basement yeah well okay now like
i look at the guys that they they got
that are free agents like tyrone
crawford who's been a hell of a player
there for a long time can you d tackle
dn but he's he's getting up there in age
he's got injury he's had a little injury
issues here like
i don't look at is that a a must-have
antoine woods he's gonna fit the dan
quinn system and shoot the one gap and
do those type of things
but again i'm not gonna sit here and go
oh my gosh if they don't have antoine
woods their team's gonna fall apart so i
really expect them to go out and find
some of the guys that like you just
mentioned you know guys that
that the money is just too much for a
certain team this year yeah they're
still a good player but the team is in a
tough spot because of the salary cap in
2021 here and they got to make a cut and
now they can finally find some of these
guys for somewhat value type signings i
think that's what we're going to see
from dallas here and i think it starts
with the front the defensive line and
then you start to get into the safety
position because if you're going to run
the dan quinn seattle defense you got to
have pretty damn good safeties we've
talked about that with all those
defensive schemes throughout the nfl
when you give me the one name on that
list give me the one name on that list
that you would that you that they must
keep who's the one guy they must keep
well i you know i the the the guy that
has the most talent there to me is like
the chidobi a woozy he's got he's a guy
that can be a corner safety he can do a
lot of different things in the back end
to where you know he could play corner
for a few more years and then he's the
type of guy because the way he tackles
and he's physical that he could be a
safety too so i almost look at him as
going hey he's in the prime of his
career you drafted him i believe what
was it the second round you know four
years ago there's a lot of positives and
the secondary's not that talented so he
would be the one guy i would look at
right there to where i'd have a mark on
him and help you hope hope we can keep
him
and and as i said there may be some
other guys out there who who want to
come play with dak i mean is dak the
kind of magnet that tom brady is i don't
know maybe now that he got this contract
he is maybe there's going to be an extra
level of of credibility an extra level
of sizzle it's still the cowboys they're
on national tv as much as any team even
when they're not relevant even when
they're not good i think maybe the jones
father and son operation will be looking
to find ways to get some guys at a
cheaper amount yeah and i'm going to get
some of that 20
7-eleven wine to go along with the giant
bottle of dom perignon that they had to
buy last night in dak prescott the deal
still wasn't done it still wasn't
officially done last night and it's
still not done today
um just minor details and still getting
figured out highly unlikely it would
fall apart yeah yeah highly unlikely it
would fall apart um
but but it's a hell of a deal for dak
prescott the cowboys only have
themselves to blame for waiting as long
as they did to do it but at the same
time it gave them another season and
change to see that that's the real deal
because the other side of that coin is
you move too quickly
and then you eventually are saying if
not sooner than that what the hell did
we do and that's what the eagles were
thinking with carson once and what the
rams were thinking with jared goff so
you know your guy
better than anyone that's right you got
to make that decision you have to make
the informed decision are you going to
make that investment and you know next
up i was talking to some people about
this last night lamar jackson
what's going to happen with lamar
jackson after this dak prescott deal
considering that lamar jackson doesn't
have an agent
and and folks look i've said this time
and again people like oh you're just
trying to help your agents well they
ain't paying me
right i listen i yeah agents are you
good agent
a good agent is there to tell you don't
take that deal right here's why you
shouldn't take that deal right a good
agent is there to say here's how you
protect yourself against getting screwed
exactly no tr no tag clause not enough
let's put some other stuff in there to
keep them from franchise tagging you now
or at any point in the future that's
where a good agent comes into play they
have the relationships they have the
understanding of the contracts you the
challenge is to find a good one i'll
concede there are some bad ones out
there i've dealt with them right but but
lamar jackson and this is the challenge
for the ravens what do we do here how
how far do we push this
you know how much is it going to look
like patrick mahomes
or dak prescott that's the range
how close to one end or the other will
lamar jackson be but the reality is
chris we'll go back to that point the
moment that lamar jackson is no longer
lamar jackson he's no longer the
starting quarterback of the baltimore
ravens period it's done it's over so you
got to get what you can while you can
right well you know and again like when
you say that when he's no more longer
like you mean like he can't run around
and do something he's not when he's not
when he's not great i get it they're not
going to pay him
a high amount of money when he's not
great yeah they would come to him and
say you're taking a pay cut we're going
to trade you we're going to cut you
whatever that's the way it works yeah no
they always are looking they always are
assessing they always are deciding are
you the best option there are no sacred
cows in the nfl so you get what you can
while you can that's the challenge and
lamar jackson's up next russell wilson's
going to be back in line at some point
aaron rodgers may be you know the way
dak prescott gave you the side eye he
may be giving even more of a side eye to
mark murphy and brian gouda koontz now
wanting his contract to be adjusted so
they're bound to him for multiple years
you know just like tom brady winning the
super bowl kind of screwed things up for
some quarterbacks this dak prescott
contract may screw some things up for
some other quarterbacks too chris yeah
no i i could see that certainly and well
i mean we heard like
that's out there right that green bay
has gone to rogers about restructuring
already back in january i believe that
was that was part of the talk so i'm
sure they'll find a way to get maybe
more guaranteed money signing bonus
something like that to to throw his way
uh
if they're trying to find ways to create
more room with the cap or anything like
that the bottom line is the jones family
they knew they got their guy this is not
carson wentz or dak or jared goff he's
not that you know he's he's extremely
talented he's been extremely consistent
and he does everything else right as far
as the intangibles so he's got tangibles
and intangibles and yeah okay
he's not you know josh allen mahomes
aaron rodgers uh russell wilson desean
watson
he's right next there though it's not
that far off it's it's you know that
people again we don't we didn't give dak
prescott the credit he deserved
for when he was playing well because
yeah it's not as sexy as russell wilson
and watson and josh allen and the
sidearm and the flair but there's so
many
subtle plays where he's got people
around him and they're grabbing at him
he throws a great throw the pocket's
collapsing and he's got to move just a
little bit and make a throw from an
awkward position with people around him
as he's going to get hit he can do that
he can run and scramble he's a legit run
threat down in the goal line so yeah
maybe not top five but he's right on the
edge looking in and if you're the dallas
cowboys you don't let a guy like that
you know get out of town and get out of
your grasp
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports